bienvenue à l'EPS
vous avez été invités ici parce que vous
faites partie des meilleurs
je voudrais savoir si vous allez encore
vous améliorer
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez être une légende
j'ai besoin d'une poubelle vous savez où
il y a une poubelle excusez-moi vous
êtes on est les Mighty Dex
j'y crois pas qu'on va faire ça je suis
certaine qu'on va bien s'amuser alors
allez-y faites-vous de nouveaux amis il
n'y a qu'une règle jouer au hockey
[Musique]
c'est ça qu'il appelle briser la glace
c'est pas un endroit normal je veux pas
dire mais le directeur il est bien
allumé
on n'est pas obligé de fuir devant le
combat moi je dis fuyant et ne nous
battons pas
des bandes de performance elle mesure le
niveau d'agilité la masse musculaire la
coordination humain
j'étais encore jamais allé en colonie de
vacances c'est toujours comme ça là
c'est pas des vacances c'est de la
torture
ça finit comme ça
on méritait d'être là autant que tous
les autres jeunes
les docks gagnent ensemble
[Applaudissements]
on a bossé trop dur on est allé trop
loin pour tout arrêter
j'en suis moi aussi
c'est du sport on joue pour gagner
vous avez appris ça à la Ligue nationale
de hockey
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de magique
il faut parfois s'affranchir des règles
pour obtenir ce qu'on fait
je voudrais que vous preniez conscience
que je vais vous ratiboiser au match
j'ai pas bien compris vous me provoquez
on dirait bien oui vous n'êtes pas très
doué je suis plutôt excellente les gens
que vous êtes moyennes il y a du progrès
j'ai passé une de ces journées
sérieusement hurle